verehrte damen und herren ich darf sie
bitten wieder platz zu nehmen
das ergebnis der wahl nicht vor
die unterbrochene sitzung ist hiermit
wieder eröffnet und sobald wir wieder im
plenum geordnet beisammen sind komme ich
zum nächsten
probieren
danke eingebracht wird
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das protokoll über die wahl des
präsidenten des 18 deutschen bundestags
weiß folgendes ergebnis auf abgegebene
stimmen 625 damit ist zugleich die
beschlussfähigkeit des deutschen des 18
deutschen bundestags festgestellt
ungültige stimmen keine gültige stimmen
mit ja haben gestimmt 591 stimmen
korrekter weise teilen mit nein haben
gestimmt 26 enthaltungen hat wir acht dr
lammert hat damit die erforderliche
mehrheit erhalten und ist zum
präsidenten des 18ten deutschen
bundestags gewählt
er sagt ich frage sie nehmen sie die
wahl an
der alterspräsident lieber kollege
riesenhuber ich nehme die wahl gerne an
herr präsident
ich gratuliere ihnen herzlich zu diesem
großartigen ergebnis auch ein ausweis
über arbeit der vergangenen periode und
ich bitte sie nachher im kurzen in einer
kurzen runde der gratulationen das
präsidium über den 18
deutschen bundestag zu übernehmen und da
der alterspräsident heinz riesenhuber ja
dieses großartige ich zitiere ihnen
ergebnis angesprochen hat wie immer fix
gerechnet 94 56 prozent zustimmung das
ist wirklich eine spektakuläre zahl
selbst wenn norbert lammert er bei
seiner ersten wahl auch schon fast 93
prozent hatte dann aber in der folgenden
legislaturperiode 84,6 prozent bekommen
hat und ansonsten so fern dass vorliegt
und nachrichten war es so die ergebnisse
für bundespräsidenten zumindest aus den
letzten jahren
dies seien wir mal bis 1989 um diesen
dreh er bei maximal 80 83 prozent
gelegen haben insofern kann man schon
sagen dass diese 94 56 prozent an
wirklich in der tat herausragendes
ergebnis sind 591 jahr stimmen und das
geht dann tatsächlich schon mutmaßlich
quer durch alle fraktionen schließlich
als 26 nein-stimmen gegeben
das hat natürlich damit zu tun wie bei
erhard scherfer dass norbert lammert
nicht nur ein meister der geschliffenen
parlamentarischen rede ist auch ein
meister der verhandlungsführung und vor
allen dingen einer ist der über den
parteien über die fraktionen hinweg die
rechte der abgeordneten immer
hochgehalten und vertreten hat manchmal
zum missfallen auch der regierung
und gerade geht er hin und übergibt und
übernimmt das amt des
bundestagspräsidenten von herrn
riesenhuber und damit auch wird beginnen
seine rede
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
exzellenzen verehrte gäste zunächst
möchte ich mich bei unserem
alterspräsidenten professor riesenhuber
für die eröffnung unserer heutigen
sitzung seine einführenden worte in die
absehbaren herausforderungen dieser
legislaturperiode und die leitung des
wahlgangs bedanken und nicht weniger
herzlich bei den beiden privaten dr
houston und dr dutzmann für die
eindrucksvolle gestaltung des
ökumenischen gottesdienstes heute morgen
ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
danke ich für ihr vertrauen
ich bin beeindruckt wie sie sich
vorstellen können von diesem votum
zumal ist ganz offenkundig sowohl von
den neun mitgliedern wie von den
langjährigen parlamentarischen
mitstreiterinnen und mitstreitern
verursacht worden ist und ich empfinde
es sowohl als ermutigung wie als
verpflichtung
besonders bedanken muss und möchte ich
mich bei meiner fraktion nämlich erneut
für dieses amt vorgeschlagen hat obwohl
sie weiß und damit rechnen muss
dass mein verständnis der damit
verbundenen aufgaben in den eigenen
reihen nicht immer stürmische
begeisterung erzeugt heute liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren konstituiert sich zum achtzehnten
mal ein deutscher bundestag
wer aus allgemeinen freien gleichen und
geheimen wahlen hervorgegangen ist
wie immer man das wahlergebnis vom 22
september und die damit verbundenen
folgen beurteilen mag dies allein ist
ein eindrucksvoller beleg für die
politische stabilität der zweiten
deutschen demokratie
die inzwischen mehr legislaturperioden
aufzuweisen hat als die weimarer
demokratie an jahren erlebt hat
der tag der konstituierung des 18ten
deutschen bundestages ist zugleich der
siebzigsten geburtstag von wolfgang
thierse diese glückliche regelung der
gesetzlichen fristen für die spätest
möglichen berufung eines neu gewählten
bundestages gibt uns die besondere
gelegenheit ihm nicht nur was der
alterspräsident bereits getan hat zu
seinem heutigen ehrentag zu gratulieren
sondern zugleich unserem früheren
präsidenten und vizepräsidenten dank zu
sagen für die langjährige arbeit in
herausragenden ämtern und funktionen
wolfgang thierse über mitglied in der
frei gewählten volkskammer der ddr
die 1990 den denkwürdigen beschluss des
beitritts der ddr zum geltungsbereich
des grundgesetzes getroffen hat er hat
über fast ein vierteljahrhundert den
ausbruch der neuen länder in die
demokratie begleitet und das
zusammenwachsen im vereinten deutschland
erfolgreich mitgestaltet unvergessen für
alle die dabei waren das sind ja noch
eine ganze reihe von kolleginnen und
kollegen
unvergessen bleibt seine prominente
rolle in der leidenschaftlichen
auseinandersetzung über den umzug von
parlament und regierung nach berlin
er war dann sieben jahre präsident des
deutschen bundestages der erste hier im
reichstagsgebäude und seitdem bis heute
vizepräsident hermann otto solms
entscheidet heute nach 33 jahren
mitgliedschaft im deutschen bundestag
darunter 15 jahren im präsidium zuvor
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion aus dem
deutschen bundestag aus ihm wie auch dem
vize präsidenten eduard oswald der zuvor
bundesminister und vorsitzender in nicht
weniger als drei unterschiedlichen
fachausschüssen des deutschen
bundestages gewesen ist möchte ich
stellvertretend für alle kolleginnen und
kollegen wie dem neuen bundestag nicht
mehr angehören unseren dank und unseren
respekt für die geleistete arbeit
aussprechen
meine damen und herren dem neuen
bundestag gehören 230 neue mitglieder an
also mehr als ein drittel weniger männer
als bisher und mehr frauen
immer noch ein paar zu wenig höre ich
aber es besteht ja doch eine famose
aussicht dass die frauen dafür die
mehrheit im präsidium des deutschen
bundestages stellen können diesen
bundestag gehören deutlich mehr jüngere
und auffällig weniger ältere mitglieder
an als in der letzten und in früheren
legislaturperioden und niemals zuvor gab
es in einem deutschen parlament so viele
abgeordnete mit einem
einwanderungshintergrund wie im 18
deutschen bundestag
sie alle wir alle übernehmen heute ein
neues mandat und den meisten wird
bewusst sein dass dies nicht ein beruf
wie jeder andere ist
nicht alle abgeordneten werden die
gleichen aufgaben und funktionen
wahrnehmen aber alle haben die gleiche
legitimation und die gleichen rechte und
pflichten
wir sollten das eine so ernst nehmen wie
das andere
die rechte wie die pflichten wir sind
alle gewählt nicht gesalbt beauftragt
zur vertretung der wahlberechtigten
nicht nur unserer jeweiligen wählerinnen
und wähler die abgeordneten des
deutschen bundestages sind vertreter des
ganzen volkes an aufträge und weisungen
nicht gebunden und nur ihrem gewissen
unterworfen heißt es unmissverständlich
im artikel 38 unseres grundgesetzes aus
gegebenem anlass weiß ich im übrigen
schon jetzt darauf hin dass wir gleich
mit der geschäftsordnung auch die
verhaltensregeln für abgeordnete
beschließen werden
die damit für alle mitglieder des hauses
gelten auch und gerade dann wenn sie
lästig sind mit der konstituierung des
bundestages endet auch die amtszeit der
regierung die ihre verfassungsrechtliche
legitimation aus der wahl des kanzlers
beziehungsweise der kanzlerin durch das
parlament bezieht auch während der dauer
der koalitionsverhandlungen ist die
handlungsfähigkeit von parlament und
regierung gesichert
und selbstverständlich bedarf eine
führend amtierende bundesregierung nicht
weniger parlamentarischer kontrolle als
eine neue und gewählt
bedanke mich insbesondere für die
demonstrative unterstützung durch die
frau bundeskanzlerin
niemand wird deshalb ernsthaft erwarten
dürfen dass der bundestag seine arbeit
erst nach abschluss der
koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen wird
beide verfassungsorgane regierung wie
parlament müssen und können ihre aufgabe
wahrnehmen zur verantwortungsübernahme
durch das parlament gibt es keine
überzeugende alternative
so hat der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts den heinz
riesenhuber schon auf der tribüne
begrüßte nicht nur in interviews immer
wieder festgehalten sondern auch in
einschlägigen urteilen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ist das so
oder ähnlich nachzulesen
zitat andreas voßkuhle
der bundestag ist und bleibt der ort an
dem die wesentlichen entscheidungen für
unser gemeinwesen getroffen werden
müssen
ende des zitats unabhängig von den
koalitionsverhandlungen und den damit
verbundenen vereinbarungen über
politische projekte der kommenden
legislaturperiode gibt es eine reihe von
parlamentarischen hausaufgaben denen wir
uns alle gemeinsam stellen müssen
die koalition wie die opposition und
drei oder vier davon möchte ich gerne
benennen
erstens geschäftsordnung die kultur
einer parlamentarischen demokratie kommt
weniger darin zum ausdruck dass am ende
mehrheiten entscheiden sondern dass
minderheiten eigene rechtsansprüche
haben die weder der billigung noch der
genehmigung durch die jeweilige mehrheit
unterliegen
die minderheit muss wissen dass am ende
die mehrheit entscheidet was will und
die mehrheit muss akzeptieren dass bis
dahin und darüber hinaus die minderheit
jede möglichkeit haben muss
ihre einwände ihre vorschläge
wenn eben möglich auch ihre alternativen
zur geltung zu bringen
nach klärung der tatsächlichen
konstellationen in diesem haus die
bahnen aber eher noch nicht kennen ist
zu klären ob und gegebenenfalls welche
änderungen dazu in der geschäftsordnung
des bundestages oder einschlägigen
gesetzlichen regelungen nötig und
möglich sind
alle fraktionen des hauses haben in den
vorbereitenden gesprächen
insbesondere im vorläufigen ältestenrat
ihre bereitschaft dazu grundsätzlich
erklärt daran können wir anknüpfen
ich will allerdings zur einordnung der
aktuellen diskussion auch den satz
hinzufügen klare wahlergebnisse sind
nicht von vornherein verfassungswidrig
große mehrheiten auch nicht
zweitens wir brauchen offensichtlich
eine neue balance zwischen der anzahl
und dem umfang der beratungs gegenstände
im deutschen bundestag und der für deren
behandlung zur verfügung stehenden zeit
in der letzten legislaturperiode ist mit
fast 15.000 drucksachen 15.000
drucksachen ein neuer wie ich finde
durchaus zweifelhaften rekord von
initiativen aller art aufgestellt worden
darunter 900 gesetzesvorhaben von denen
am ende 553 verabschiedet worden
auch möglicherweise eher ein paar zu
viel als zu wenig auch wenn die meisten
großen und kleinen anfragen
entschließungsanträge
beschlussempfehlungen berichte und
sonstige initiativen jeweils ihren sinn
haben
es sind zu viel
jedenfalls deutlich mehr
jedenfalls deutlich mehr als wir in der
dafür zur verfügung stehenden
beratungszeit mit der gebotenen sorgfalt
erledigen können dies wird im übrigen
auch in der allzu großen anzahl von
tagesordnungspunkten deutlich die ohne
debatte behandelt werden
deswegen werden wir an der unangenehmen
entscheidung nicht vorbeikommen entweder
die zahl der sitzungswochen deutlich zu
erhöhen oder unseren gemeinsamen ehrgeiz
in der produktion von texten und
papieren stärker zu disziplinieren
parlamente sind im übrigen wolfgang
thierse hat in seinen abschluss
bemerkungen bei der letzten sitzung der
vergangenen legislaturperiode daran
erinnert parlamente sind keine
instrumente zur beschleunigung von
entscheidungen sondern zur legitimierung
von entscheidungen die allgemein
verbindlich gelten sollen dies setzt
eine sorgfalt und gründlichkeit voraus
die dem beschleunigungs ehrgeiz
widerstehen muss von wem auch immer er
jeweils geltend gemacht wird
drittens dass weder die
regierungsbefragung noch die
fragestunden in ihrer bisherigen
struktur das glanzstück des deutschen
parlamentarismus darstellen ist
inzwischen ein breiter konsens
deswegen sollten wir in der lage sein
beides in einer lebendigeren die
aufgaben des parlaments gegenüber der
regierung akzentuieren weise neu zu
regeln
viertens schließlich es gibt anders noch
einmal in ruhe und gründlich auf das
novellierte wahlrecht zu schauen
auch wenn das wahlergebnis vom 22
september nur zu einer maßvollen
ausweitung der anzahl der mandate
geführt hat ganze vier überhangmandate
viel weniger als sie den allermeisten
früheren legislaturperioden ganze vier
überhangmandate haben durch die neuen
berechnungsmethode des fortgeschriebenen
wahlrechts die für die meisten
wahlberechtigten übrigens ziemlich
undurchsichtig sind zu 29
ausgleichsmandaten geführt dies lässt
die folge nahmen die sich bei einem
anderen knappen wahlausgang für die
größenordnung künftiger parlamente
ergeben könnten
und da es immer besser ist sich mit
solchen entwicklungen dann auseinander
zu setzen wenn die probleme noch nicht
eingetreten sind spricht manches dafür
dass wir nicht erst nach der nächsten
wahl sondern rechtzeitig vor der
nächsten wahl noch einmal einen
gemeinsamen sorgfältigen blick auf diese
regelungen werfen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren die bedeutung und
leistung des bundestages sind gewiss
höher als ein öffentliches ansehen
die kritik am parlamentarismus ist nicht
neu sie ist vielmehr ziemlich genau so
alt wie der parlamentarismus selbst das
macht sie allerdings nicht weniger
bedeutsam tatsächlich bestimmen nicht
nur die verfassung und die darin
formulierten aufgaben den kritischen
befund sondern die in der öffentlichkeit
entwickelten ansprüche und erwartungen
und diese lassen sich schon deshalb
nicht in vollem umfang erfüllen weil sie
sich teilweise wechselseitig
ausschließen
dies kann man besonders gut erkennen am
klassischen spannungsverhältnis zwischen
der erwartung eines möglichst
geschlossenen auftretens
parlamentarischer gruppierungen auf der
einen seite insbesondere natürlich von
fraktionen und regierungskoalition und
der erwarteten unabhängigkeit der
abgeordneten mit ihrem
verfassungsrechtlich garantierten freien
mandat auf der anderen seite wenn es in
diesem haus übrigens tatsächlich große
mehrheiten geben sollte wird die
urteilsbildung der eigenen der einzelnen
abgeordneten auch und gerade in der
koalition nicht weniger wichtig sondern
noch wichtiger als bei knappen
mehrheiten
ein parlament das forum der nation sein
soll und sein will muss die ganze breite
der auffassungen und meinungen zur
geltung bringen die es unter den
abgeordneten und den durch sie
vertretenen wählerinnen und wählern in
unserer gesellschaft gibt dies geschieht
in der regel über die fraktionen muss
aber gegebenenfalls auch unabhängig von
ihnen möglich sein
die offene rede herr kollege riesenhuber
ist nicht nur in der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft möglich sondern auch hier
und manchmal sogar nötig der bundestag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hat in
der letzten legislaturperiode nicht nur
an selbstbewusstsein gewonnen sondern
auch an einklagbaren zuständigkeiten der
bundestag beschränkt sich keineswegs auf
die notarielle beurkundung anderswo
getroffene entscheidungen mit blick auf
europäische verträge und vereinbarungen
ist er inzwischen selbst am
zustandekommen der verträge und
verpflichtungen beteiligt die am ende
ratifiziert oder auch nicht und damit
rechtsverbindlich macht es gibt durchaus
anlass zur besorgnis über manche
entwicklungen in europa in einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten oder auch in der union
im ganzen aber es gibt kein parlament in
europa das darauf größeren einfluss hat
als der deutsche bundestag meine damen
und herren es gibt keine demokratie ohne
transparenz und kontrolle ohne kritische
beobachtung geht es nicht aber ein auf
dauer gesetztes misstrauen zerstört
nicht nur jede persönliche beziehung
sondern macht auch die wahrnehmung
öffentlicher mandate unmöglich dass ein
mandatsträger höhere erwartungen
gestellt werden als an anderen ist
offensichtlich und auch durchaus
angemessen
es muss aber in einem nachvollziehbaren
menschengerechten maß erfolgen
auch abgeordnete haben mit der annahme
ihres mandats nicht ihre
staatsbürgerlichen grundrechte verwirkt
ein parlament ist keine versammlung von
helden und heiligen sondern von
volksvertretern
dies gilt im übrigen nicht nur für die
verfassungs theorie sondern auch für die
gesellschaftliche wirklichkeit eine
ziemlich repräsentative mischung von
herkunft alter berufen begabungen
temperamenten erfahrungen stärken und
schwächen nicht besser als andere aber
in der regel auch nicht schlechter
volksvertreter george bernard shaw ja
kein parlamentarier war aber ein kluger
beobachter gesellschaftlicher
entwicklungen wird der satz
zugeschrieben
die demokratie ist die einzige
staatsform die sicherstellt dass wir
nicht besser regiert werden als wir es
verdienen
mit dieser ebenso ernüchternden wie
ermutigenden einsicht sollten wir uns
mit gottes hilfe an die arbeit machen
damit dieses land etwa so regiert wird
wie es die menschen die hier leben
erwarten und verdienen
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit bei ihnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für die
unterstützung und ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit in der neuen
legislaturperiode